Es wird Zeit, euch mal wieder auf den neuesten Stand zu bringen über den europäischen Fußball der Männer. Wir wollen heute sprechen über die Lage in der Liga, in der Premier League, in La Liga, in der Eredivisie und in der Serie A mit Uli Hebel, Daniel Zander, Fabian Pakulat und Christian Bernhard jetzt hier in der Ligatur und Abfahrt. Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Ich sag's ganz ehrlich, diese Sendung, die musste reingepresst werden, wie eine Scheibe Käse in ein dicke, voll bepacktes Sandwich, aber ich habe eure Rufe erhört, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, hier ist mal wieder eine Europa Ligatur und ich freu mich sehr, dass meine Runde hier ist. Hallo in die Runde.
Und wie wird das verfolgt in Spanien? Ich meine, klar, auf einmal ist es so, dass alle mit den entsprechenden Fähnchen die Europapokalspiele von anderen verfolgen, weil sie hoffen, dass die jetzt alle die Titel holen, damit es dann wirklich neun Europapokal-Teilnehmer der Liga wären. Aber eigentlich ist ja mit dem UEFA-Koeffizienten jetzt das eingetreten, was man erwartet hatte damals, als es eingeführt wurde, als es quasi hieß, die beiden besten Ligen bekommen noch mal zwei zusätzliche Plätze. Und dann haben alle gesagt, ah ja, der geht dann an die Premier League und der geht an La Liga. Dann war es im ersten Jahr nicht so. Da hat ja unter anderem Deutschland davon profitiert. Ist das jetzt quasi die Herstellung der natürlichen Ordnung? Wie wird denn das in Spanien begleitet?
Ja, also die Spanier sind schon sehr selbstbewusst. Und sie sehen sich schon europäisch ganz weit vorne. Und von daher glaube ich, sind sie da schon so stolz, dass sie sagen, ja, den haben wir uns schon auch verdient. Ist ja auch im Endeffekt so. Man muss ja auch wirklich sagen, in den letzten Jahren, die Spanier sind eigentlich immer, im Halbfinale war immer ein Spanier dabei mindestens. Und in der Champions League mit Real Madrid haben wir ja genug erlebt, sag ich mal, in den letzten Jahren, wie oft sie es gewonnen haben. Also die sind schon auf europäischer Ebene wirklich sehr hoch anzusiedeln. Es gibt da natürlich schon Gefälle. Jetzt auch in der Conference League oder Europa League haben es nicht alle Teams gut gemacht, wie auch San Sebastian zum Beispiel. Da ist es dann nicht ganz so einfach. Aber so diese ersten vier, fünf, sechs Teams vielleicht in Spanien, die sind schon normalerweise in Europa immer sehr gut dabei.
Also wir werden es genau verfolgen. Ich danke euch beiden. Und wenn alles geklappt hat, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, dann hören wir jetzt noch einen Aufsager von Christian zur Serie A. Es tut uns sehr leid, dass wir es nicht anders hinbekommen haben. Aber bitte, Christian, take it away, wie es im Sportradio 360 immer heißt. Wie ist die Lage in der Serie A?
Was das Rennen um die Europapokalplätze betrifft, Max, können wir es in Italien fast um einen Rennen um die Champions League-Plätze ausweiten. Denn– Achtung– bis zur achtplatzierten Fiorentina haben alle noch wirklich realistische Chancen, sich für die Champions League zu qualifizieren. Zwischen Juve auf Platz 4 und der Fiorentina auf 8 liegen nur drei Punkte. Und das Schöne ist, dass all die Mannschaften, die damit drin sind– also Atalanta, Juve, Bologna, Roma, Lazio und die Fiorentina– an den letzten vier Spieltagen noch mehrfach gegeneinander spielen. Also jeder dieser Teams hat noch mindestens ein direktes Duell. Mehrere Mannschaften, zum Beispiel Juve sogar zwei, die haben jetzt zunächst Bologna, dann kriegen sie noch Lazio. Also alles direkte Duelle. Dementsprechend haben sie alle Mannschaften auch eigentlich noch selbst in der Hand. Und ja, schauen wir uns mal kurz uns an, Mannschaft für Mannschaft, wie da die Chancen stehen. Beginnen wir mit Atalanta. Die sind auf 3, die haben ein kleines Polster auf Rang 5, nämlich 4 Punkte. Also da deutet jetzt einiges drauf hin, dass Atalanta diesen dritten Platz sozusagen holen wird. Warum? Weil sie zuletzt wichtige, Stichwort direkte Duelle für sich entschieden haben. Haben zuletzt Milan geschlagen, haben zu Lotz Bologna geschlagen, vor einigen Wochen auch Juve geschlagen. Also, obwohl es bei Atalanta in den vergangenen Wochen ja auch nicht immer rund lief, aber gerade in diesen direkten Duellen waren sie da. Und dementsprechend deutet jetzt vieles darauf hin, dass Gasperini und seine Elf auf ein paar Champions-League-Plätze einlaufen werden. Auf 4 ist Juve. Da müsste man eigentlich irgendwann dann auch mal, Max, noch eine eigene Sendung machen, denn da wir jetzt so eine lange Pause hatten, mittlerweile ist Thiago Motta ja gar nicht mehr Trainer bei Juve, sondern das Kapitel ist ja bereits Geschichte. Igor Tudor hat Juve übernommen und hat es in den ersten fünf Spielen sehr ordentlich bis gut gemacht. Juve hat drei dieser fünf Spiele gewonnen. Dazu gab es ein Unentschieden gegen die Roma, so ein bisschen aus der Reihe tanzt die Niederlage in Parma. Aber wie gesagt, Juve hat sich stabilisiert, konnte, äh, konnte es schon, sorry, Tudor hat aufgrund seiner langjährigen Juve-Vergangenheit das irgendwie geschafft, sozusagen da ein bisschen wieder eine positive Stimmung reinzubekommen. Also sowohl die Spieler als auch das Umfeld nimmt ihm diese lange Juve-Geschichte ab, hat relativ simple Sachen gemacht, hat jetzt immer dasselbe System spielen lassen, 3-4-2-1, auch die meisten Positionen sehr verlässlich besetzt, also anders als Thiago Motta, der wahnsinnig viel rotiert hat. Also Tudor scheint da wie gesagt einen ganz guten Schlüssel jetzt gefunden zu haben, um Juve da eben in diesen letzten Spielen in die Champions League zu bringen, was hier das große Ziel sozusagen ist. Wie gesagt, die Besonderheit, sie haben jetzt noch Bologna und Lazio, also hintereinander zwei direkte Konkurrenten. Und Kinnenhildis ist am vergangenen Wochenende wegen einer Tätigkeit mit Rot vom Platz geflogen. Ich gehe mal stark davon aus, dass der mehrere Spiele sperren bekommen wird. Also der wird Juve jetzt definitiv fehlen, aber Juve ist eigentlich in diesen engen Rennen schon in einer ganz guten Position. Gehen wir auf Rang 5, da liegt Bologna. Für mich ja eigentlich die Mannschaft fast des Jahres, wieder noch Serie A. Also was Vincenzo Italiano, die Arbeit fortgeführt hat von Thiago Motta, sensationell. Dazu kommt bei Bologna, dass sie auch noch im Coppa Italia-Finale sind gegen Milan. Jetzt in zwei Wochen, also auch da noch eine Aussicht auf einen großen Titel, der Bologna schon lange fehlt. Große Arbeit, die Bologna leistet, wie gesagt, einfach mitten in dem Rennen drin zu sein. Sie haben Juve noch, das direkte Duell zu Hause. Also auch Bologna hat alle Möglichkeiten, diesen vierten Platz sich selbst zu ergattern. Kleine negative Rande und Lütze, Denen Deuje, der Schweizer Nationalspieler, der hat sich jetzt vor wenigen Tagen verletzt, droht wohl auch, mehrere Wochen auszufallen. Warum erwähne ich ihn? Weil er wirklich einer der formstärksten, einer sehr formstarken Bologna-Mannschaft zuletzt war, also das wird jetzt Bologna treffen. Aber die große Qualität von Bologna liegt eigentlich schon die ganze Saison darin, dass sie eben vielfältig aufgestellt sind. Orsolini zuletzt wieder, ganz wichtige Tore, mehrere wichtige, schöne Tore, auch das späte Sieg der Nachspielzeit gegen Inter erst vor kurzem. Also Italiano hat mehrere Optionen und ich würde sagen, da ist auch eine gewisse Leichtigkeit bei Bologna dabei, denn anders als Juve oder eben andere große Namen, wenn die schon den großen Druck haben, in die Champions League fast kommen zu müssen, ist das eigentlich bei Bologna kein Muss, sondern ein schönen Traum, den sie weiter verfolgen. Die ganze Stadt steht dahinter, das ganze Umfeld. Vor kurzem waren mal beim Training 2000 Fans, 2000 unter der Woche und das zeigt eben, dass da eine große positive Stimmung da ist. Dazu noch das Coppa Italia-Finale, also mit Bologna ist zu rechnen. Dahinter haben wir die Roma. Die Roma, einfach nur ein Wort, sensationell, was Claudio Ranieri mit der Roma gemacht hat. Noch mal zur Erinnerung, als er die übernommen hat, hatte die Roma 2 Punkte Vorsprung auf den Abstiegsplatz, auf den ersten. So, und jetzt sind 4 Spieltage vor Schluss, liegen nur noch 2 Punkte hinter den Champions League-Rängen. Seit 19 Spielen jetzt mittlerweile ungeschlagen. Eben am vergangenen Sonntag der Sieg in San Siro gegen Inter. Das nächste Statement, was Ranieri gemacht hat, einfach großartig. Die Roma ist schwer zu knacken. Die Roma funktioniert auch ohne Di Balla, der mittlerweile schon seit einigen Wochen verletzungsbedingt fehlt. Zuletzt waren es wieder Sole, der das entscheidende Tor gegen Inter gemacht hat, oder Schomo Rodolf, oder auch Cristante zum Beispiel, der ein großes Spiel gerade in San Siro gegen das Inter Mittelfeld geliefert hat. Spieler, die zum Beispiel vor einigen Monaten überhaupt keine Rolle gespielt haben und die es eben Ranieri auch geschafft hat, wieder auf Kurs zu bringen. Also alleine, dass die Roma ja noch die reelle Chance auf die Champions League hat, ist eigentlich ein kleines fußballerisches Wunder. Die Roma hatten wahrscheinlich das schwerste Restprogramm von allen, aber eben wie gesagt, allein durch den Dreier jetzt gegen Inter haben sie auch gezeigt, dass sie auch in den direkten Duellen da noch einiges bewegen können. Und deswegen einfach, ja, ich sage mal, der positive Schwung, der ist definitiv auf Seiten der Roma. Dahinter Lazio, Punkt gleich mit der Roma, auch nur zwei Punkte hinter der vierplatzierten Juve. Ja, ist zuletzt vielleicht ein bisschen ins Stocken geraten. Lazio war ja vor einigen Wochen noch durchaus in der Pole-Position, was diesen, sage ich mal, vierten Rang betrifft. Zuletzt ja auch in der Europa League ausgeschieden, aber eben auch weiterhin voll im Rennen. Hat eben noch das Direkturale gegen Juve, wo sie rein theoretisch eben mit einem Sieg an Juve vorbeiziehen können. Haben Tati Castellanos wieder zurück. Der Neuner, der Mittelstürmer, der hat ihnen wochenlang gefehlt. Und da hat man auch gesehen, dass der offensive Output darunter gelitten hat, nicht nur aufgrund der Tore des Argentiniers, sondern auch aufgrund seines großen Einflusses auf das Laziospiels, macht viele Bälle fest, ist einfach ein Neuner, der für diese Mannschaft sehr wichtig ist. Pedro am vergangenen Wochenende wieder mit einem Doppelpack, also auch die Erfahrung von Pedro tut der Lazio gut. Und ich würde auch sagen, sie haben auch so ein bisschen Außenseiter. Es sind in der Außenseiterrolle, also ich glaube nicht, dass von Lazio jetzt unbedingt verlangt wird, dass sie in die Champions League müssen. Dementsprechend können sie das vielleicht auch ein bisschen befreiter angehen. Ja, und dann haben wir noch die Fiorentina auf Rang 8, die liegt drei Punkte hinter dem vierten Platz, hat zuletzt auch wieder aufsteigende Formen bewiesen, hat Robin Goossens, das muss man da hervorheben, hat zuletzt einige wichtige Tore geschossen, eben auf der linken Außenbahn. Ken hat jetzt ein, zwei Spiele gefehlt aus persönlichen Gründen, der kommt hoffentlich wieder zurück, das ist logisch ganz wichtig für die Fiorentina, die auch noch im Conference League-Halbfinale ist, das dürfen wir auch nicht vergessen. Also die haben wirklich auch noch eine Zusatzbelastung mit mindestens zwei Spielen mehr. Das macht es jetzt sicherlich nicht einfach im Kampf um Platz 4. Und was bei der Fiorentina sicherlich jetzt negativ ins Gewicht schlagen könnte, ist, dass Dodor, der rechte Schienenspieler, der wie groß und extrem wichtig für die Mannschaft ist, erstmal ausfällt, weil er am Blinddarm operiert wurde. Aber trotzdem, auch bei der Fiorentina, sie sind im Rennen, sie sind mittendrin und auch die Fiorentina hat noch ein direktes Duell. Also auch da ist alles noch möglich. Und der letzte Satz vielleicht noch, denn auf 9 liegt Milan, also eigentlich eine dieser Mannschaften, die man auf jeden Fall unter den Top 4 hatten, die haben wirklich 8 Punkte Rückstand auf Platz 4. Also das Ding ist eigentlich durch die Champions League. Bei Milan liegen jetzt die großen Hoffnungen auf das Coppa Italia-Finale. Sie haben ja Inter rausgeworfen im Halbfinale und würden da mit einem Sieg sich sozusagen als Coppa Italia-Sieger sich direkt für die Europa League qualifizieren. Das ist jetzt sicherlich das große Ziel von Milan, um diese Saison, die dann zwar am Ende mit zwei Titeln enden könnte, denn die Supercoppa haben es ja schon gewonnen, dann trotzdem eine sehr, sehr schwierige Saison zu beenden. Denn ein Kader von Milan, also mit diesen Einzelspielern als neunter in der Liga nach 34 Spieltagen, das zeigt schon, wie viel schief bei Milan in dieser Saison in der Liga gelaufen ist.
Danke, Christian, für deine Infos. Und ich danke natürlich auch Daniel und Fabian, dass ihr hier allen technischen Widrigkeiten getrotzt habt. Man muss auch sagen, derjenige, der den Stromausfall hatte gestern, wo überhaupt nicht klar, wie lange das gehen würde, der war mit weitem Abstand am Stabiesten hier mit dabei. Fabian, ich ziehe meinen Hut, nicht schlecht.
Man muss den Spanien eins lassen, Internet, wenn es Strom gibt, dann ist das Internet wirklich top. Dann ist es wirklich top und auch sehr, sehr günstig. Also von daher freut mich, dass alles geklappt hat.
Aber wirklich, was für ein Satz auch einfach, wenn es Strom gibt, dann ist das Internet wirklich super. Ganz kurz, ich muss die Frage einmal kurz stellen, wie war denn das gestern mit dem Stromausfall? Das ist ja auf eine Art und Weise bezahlbar, weil wie hat zum Beispiel dann das Weitergeben von Nachrichten funktioniert? Weil ja auch Radiosender etc. keinen Strom hatten.
Die Radiosender waren die ersten, die wieder gesendet haben und plötzlich waren sämtliche Transistorenradios, also diese alten Radios, wo man noch die Frequenz einstellt, ausverkauft. Hast du so eins? Nein, ja natürlich nicht. Natürlich nicht. Ich bin ins Auto gegangen und habe im Auto ein Radio gehört. Im Auto gibt es das natürlich. Da gibt es ja noch die Antenne um. Also habe ich im Auto ein bisschen Radio gehört. Aber es war tatsächlich so, wir sind dann runtergekommen. Alle Supermärkte, alles hat zugemacht natürlich. Die Einzigen, die noch auf haben, waren so kleine Chinesen. Die haben halt alles Mögliche. Und die haben aufgelassen und dann sind wir zu zwei, drei verschiedenen hin und wollten so ein kleines Radio haben und alles ausverkauft natürlich. Die Spanier haben sofort angefangen mit Hamsterkäufen. Also Klopapier, Wasser, alles wurde sofort wieder für die nächsten fünf Jahre gekauft und so weiter. Und es war echt bizarr.
Aber ohne Kartenzahlung ja auch. Du musst ja dann Bargeld zahlen. Ja eben, wer hat denn Bargeld zu Hause? Oh Gott, ich wäre völlig… im Falle eines Ernstfalls bin ich komplett aufgeschmissen.
Ihr müsst die EU folgen bzw. es gibt diesen Survival-Kit oder was auch immer. Ich glaube, man sollte ihn sich tatsächlich…
Es gibt es für Deutschland auch, ja.
Es macht Sinn. Also ich bin mal gespannt, was rauskommt. Wir wissen ja nach wie vor nicht, was der Grund war. Es war plötzlich um 12.30 Uhr 60% des Stroms weg und das hat dazu geführt, dass das gesamte Netz kollabiert ist. Es gibt die Theorie, dass in Frankreich bzw. dass Spanien in Frankreich dann vom europäischen Netz abgekoppelt worden ist. Warum weiß man nicht. Es gibt die Theorie, dass zu viel Photovoltaik produziert worden ist bzw. zu viele erneuerbare Egenen und dass das System dadurch kollapsiert worden ist. Es gibt natürlich auch die Theorie der Cyber-Attacke. Wir wissen es noch nicht, aber es war schon bizarr, wenn man überlegt, einige Haushalte haben erst heute Morgen wieder Strom bekommen. Das sind dann mehr als 12 Stunden ohne Strom. Bei uns waren es nur vier. Wir hatten echt viel Glück. Und das ist schon heftig eigentlich. Ja, interessant, was wir so in den letzten Jahren hier alles erleben. Wir haben mit Covid angefangen und dann die Wasserfluten und jetzt Stromausfall.
Also, du nimmst es auch wirklich mit. Ich meine, wir haben hier eine Ligatur aufgenommen während Corona in der einen Stunde, in der Kinder und Familie raus durften. Du hast gesagt, nee, lasst uns trotzdem eine Ligatur aufnehmen, wo ich bis heute ein schlechtes Gewissen habe. Dann eben diese Niederschläge. Jetzt das. Also es ist absolut bizarr. Und ich kann euch nur empfehlen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, schaut euch mal das an. Es gibt von der Bundesregierung, was man quasi haben soll, unter anderem Konservendosen für drei Monate. Ich glaube, 100 Liter Wasser soll man einfach immer da haben. Viel Spaß mit, das in eurer völlig überteuerten Mietwohnung in einer Großstadt irgendwo in dem anderthalb Zimmer noch unterzubringen. Also absolut. Gut, und ich meine, dass für mich sowieso sämtliche Perspektive auch beruflich futsch ist, sollte es mal irgendwie keinen Strom geben. Das ist ja auch völlig klar. Dann kommt ja nicht mal mehr euer Support bei uns an, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Gott um Gottes Willen, bald muss ich hier Barspenden einsammeln. Also schön, dass es dennoch geklappt hat, Fabian. Und ich bin gespannt, was quasi dann im nächsten Jahr passiert. Es ist ja immer so jährlich ein großes Ding. Aber trotzdem, bei dir hat es geklappt. Danke dir und ich danke natürlich auch Daniel Zander. Keine Ahnung, warum du auch mehrmals wegfasst. Ich weiß auch gar nicht, ob es überhaupt ein Video gegeben haben wird zu dieser Sendung hier. Aber ich danke dir, dass auch du allem getrotzt hast und mir das vor allem mit den Playoffs erklären konntest. Wahnsinn, dass ich das nicht wusste. Und ich schimpfe mich Sportjournalist. Wahnsinn.
Danke dir.
Gerne, gerne.
Gerne wieder.
Und dann danke ich natürlich auch in Abwesenheit Christian Bernhard und Uli Hebel. Und ich danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörern, entschuldigt das Ganze hin und her. Ich hoffe, es war für euch dennoch ein Hörgenuss unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de. Da könnte uns gerne Feedback zu dieser Sendung geben. Und in der Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Jule Jakob, Tobias Gebhardt, mit dem Jürgen bei Simon Gofegantse-Johann und bei Eresi von der Alm. Esresi von der Alm, sie alle sind Rasenfunk-Supporter. Erinnern auf rasenfunk.de, erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Noch nicht in Bar, aber alles andere geht. Und vielleicht muss ich das mit Frank demnächst mal besprechen. Und ansonsten wünsche ich euch eine gute Zeit. Hört dem Rasenfunk auch den anderen Feeds. Es wird hier heute noch eine weitere Ligatur zur 2. Liga geben. Es wird ein Tribüngespräch geben. Schwerpunkt zu Leverkusen bei den Männern. Und die Spieltags-Sendungen zur Frauen-Bundesliga und zur Männer-Bundesliga, die sind ja schon erschienen. Also es gibt viel, viel, viel zu hören. Und vielleicht auch viele Gründe, den Rasenfunk zu unterstützen. Ganz herzlichen Dank an alle, die das schon getan haben. Bleibt gesund und macht keine Hamster-Korte weg. Bis bald. Ciao. Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.